welcome all we are going to divide the
session in two first we are going to
have
main presentations of our cases and then
we are we will like to open a space of
discussion with our panelists so I would
like to introduce you to have it Clemens
Harry Clemens is a program officer of
carbon finance in evils the humanist
Institute of development cooperation
Harry
so I'll start then maybe you can start
the slides here so I will talk about
well I will give one presentation on one
of the cases about the relationship
between agriculture and climate change
with also incorporating climate finance
that's the case of the bio slurry by a
flurry which is used as fertilizer in
connection with with biogas domestic
biogas so the next the first slide yeah
so here you can see the basic design of
the bio digester we have programs of
biogas and by lorry in several countries
of Africa Asia and Latin America and the
basic it's a household level so these
are small digesters the basic design is
a fixed dome design of we have in
between four cubic and thirteen cubic
meter and so you can see on the picture
that on the left side there's the the
wet organic waste
that's the inflow so usually it's a
livestock manure and also human equity
so you need to put the the manure the
left side it flows into the digester
there it is the process of the digesting
so after yeah after some 20 to 30 days
it starts producing the gas the cost
goes up and by the cost
sure the the digester slurry gets on the
pressure and they'll be put out to the
right so that the effluent that is the
bios slurry that will automatically go
out and that's the fertilizer that we
will be talking about so the design is
that we manage usually in the he force
and S&T programs
it's the fixed dome design coach on the
ground you have other models but this is
a model that is quite quite solid so it
is a usual lifetime of it 20 years or
longer so but the investment cost is not
so low but it varies between countries
in general Asia is much cheaper than
Africa and also then Latin America now
so the construction cost would be in
between three hundred and fifteen eight
hundred dollars in Asia and between 600
and 1,000 dollars in Africa and also in
Latin America so it has basically two
products no the biogas for cooking and
lighting and also the by slurry is
volcanic fertilizer so the next light
please yeah so here you can see the the
well the two products are the the bio
castes in the in the Vice slurry but
there are multiple benefits so it
decided the programs they create local
employment now at the the the gas which
is a clean cooking fuel so it has yeah
the cooking which is convenient fast
healthy and there's also the lighting
option or well better to say the
aggregate for those households that
don't have electricity
the lighting is also a nice benefit and
then there's the fertilizer so next like
this
so the bios slurry there's a yes I
mentioned the supreme fertilizer it can
be applied in three different forms now
it can be applied directly in a liquid
form that has added the digester slurry
is beneficial because it's readily
available the nutrients so the liquid
form can be absorbed by the and used by
the plant directly the disadvantages
that yet a heavy and it's not so
convenient to do transport so when when
the farmer uses it for longer distances
they often dry it and then the third
alternative is to compost it and that
would be the best form but well that
depends on the niche no so the most
common or the most popular model is six
cubic metre and that is sufficient for
one fertilizing one hectare on average
and if you compost it with organic waste
you can yeah you can use product you
have fertilizer for about three hectares
of course all this variable it's depends
on the crop and the specific needs and
that also is for the for the revenues
and the yield increases so actually we
have made a document with all the yeah
the different results in in practice how
yields are increasing in different crops
so I brought some copies of that that
will be at the SNP booth here in the
yeah in the in the one of those buffers
so there you can see in more detail the
benefits of the slurry but on average is
25 percent revenue increase compared to
the the the raw manure so next slide
please
okay so at those programs that we have
in society in Africa Asia and Latin
America well in Africa does the African
biogas partnership program that's in
five countries we have an Indonesia and
Cambodia so now we have carbon projects
registered for biogas in four countries
and in validation for the other
countries we will focus now on the Kenya
and Indonesia because that's where we
are working also on the by slurry part
on the energy part
hence it is already registered in Kenyan
Indonesia Kenya case by the CDM is a
renewable energy project so they're what
you quantify is the replacement of of
firewood now and also but that's more in
Indonesia and in Cambodia there's also
the manual management because there's no
methane emissions in the raw menu so
Indonesia domestic biogas project is
registered in the voluntary code
standard in 2013 and on average we are
all variable but on average it's Fortin
co2 per household so there's four carbon
credits per household
that's for the energy part so that is
the part that is fitting into the the
current called standard
and CDM method approve methodologies but
it does not recognize the part for the
bios slurry so now we are working with
the gold standard as the gold standard
launched maybe you have seen it launched
this week the the gold standard
agriculture standard and was last
Wednesday and so and now we can work on
the methodologies to be approved to to
quantify the impact on carbon
sequestration and fertilizer replacement
by the by the base salary and we are
working on that it's yeah the depends on
where you use it many different crops
and and how you use it in liquid form or
in the dried form on the composite form
so that makes we are different
situations here maybe the next lighting
yeah okay so do we we are working there
for the soil and more no that's a
specialized company so they have
produced the methodology white paper so
an initial methodology for the for the
measurement of the carbon impact of bio
celery we have done by celery use the
surface in Kenya and Indonesia and we
have now also the feasibility study for
Indonesia based on that to use a surface
so we have made a baseline scenario
project basic scenario probably plus
scenario and that's basically because
it's so different in the different types
of applications so most people now use
it in the liquid or right form and only
small percentage in the composite form
there and so the initial calculations is
that with the project basic scenario
with that mix of applications it's 2.4
tonne per hectare that if we if up to
70% of the users would make composite
and it would go up to 5 points written
the hectare and then well on average the
farmers they have 0.6 hectares those
that are in the in the survey so that's
more or less see we dedicated the case
description just still one more slide ok
yeah so it's a kind of a landscape plus
I would say because it has the bio
khasimbai story in combination it really
has all three elements of the landscape
the reduced deforestation or because of
the substitutes the replacement of of
the firewood it has the improved
agriculture and it is also reinforcing
the integrated livestock and crops
system and it has the energy system so
and besides that it also is let's say
the plus because it's about lively oats
it's about food security there's a very
strong health benefit that there's the
time savings because especially
important for the women because they in
many places are to collect the wood and
there's the income generation both by
the users and by the constructor so baby
yeah I've not mentioned yet that it's a
market-based approach we train construct
Mason's
they form small enterprises and so
there's also the local employment
economy part so that's yeah let's say
netscape's plus thank you
I kindly ask you all do to maintain your
questions to the end and I want to
introduce now to Francisco Fonseca a
senior researcher and adviser of zydeco
yes it works well I work for saveco
which is an NGO based in Costa Rica we
work in some other countries in Latin
America Sudoku is needed a sport for
about 30 years
you know sustainable agriculture and we
also have developed methodology named
cambio dos which is proper for measuring
carbon sequestration from sustainable
practice in just a lot of farming the
I'm going to present you some of the
results we already have after somehow
like one and a half years working
together with the gold standard this is
one of the six projects selected to
implement agriculture methodologies that
may be used for the new standard of the
gold standard this whole process is
being sponsored by he was from from the
Netherlands next one
so pacifying is the name of the project
it stands for sustained agree culture in
coffee plantations in Nicaragua in
Spanish of course we are working with a
quite important organization a
cooperative second level cooperative
named por el de Kaap the it is
cooperative covers around 38 different
cups and we picked three two
cooperatives from two different
departments in in the northern part of
Nicola over there placed were most of
the high quality coffee comes from
Nicaragua one co-operative was
conventional plus for trade under the
co-operative implement organic practice
certified as well plus portray from them
we picked 45 farms to implement the
computers methodology
in the film what some key aspects to be
remind from these cooperatives are that
they are a great system our forces
systems that means that they have
already established four trees into the
coffee plantations for Shailene and our
expect to be remind important is that
they apply almost nothing very low to
nothing
fertilizers so they have very low yields
and because of the under Nernst
condition of the plants they are
affected thoroughly severely for the
coffee leave rust and other diseases so
that's something that we want to tackle
next one please
so in an eventual project with carbon
credits satisfied by the gold standard
we would expect to be these carbon
credits to be invested in a composting
facility to improve yields and to have a
better way to manage the the sanitary
aspects of the plants and we already
said that they are real trees in the in
the systems so the carbon will come from
the aerial biomass that they said the
leaves and parts of the trees that comes
to falsehood into the ground and add to
carbon to the soil and soil carbon
biomass and avoided emissions that comes
from the substitution from chemical
fertilizers and now using compost or
organic fertilizers so in a twenty years
period this trail will be added from the
trees and from adding applying composing
in the field that will add carbon to the
soil and will avoid emissions to the to
the to the Earth's atmosphere
nice
so these one pre-action we have made
some model with ROTC model we have done
this prediction calculating to satisfy
the 60% of nitrogen for the coffee plant
for them to increase yields that
something that they cannot achieve
currently and so this is the forecast an
example the forecast accumulation rate
per year per hectare in 20 years that
will be used for for the carbon credits
estimation in the future the next one
here we have two variables is one is
yields expected yields and emissions so
we have organic on the top and bottom
and the bulk of conventional farmers on
the top we see with the purple bars
there is the situation where there is no
project so in the organic farms Jews
will remain about the same you can see
in the red line that emissions will be
about the same emissions of greenhouse
gases but having the project we may
expect these yields to increase by year
six to almost double but we can see it
in the blue line that emissions will go
up as well I'm going to that later
you know sly for conventional farmers
the spectators will be that you can see
again in the purple bars they will have
more similar yields it depends on coffee
price and the cost of fertilizers but we
can see that they would be parallel to
increments of the carbon emission due to
the chemical fertilizers with the
project we would SPECT the day to
increase whether the the deal we can see
in the in the green bars but we see in
the blue line that the emissions will be
reduced because of the substitution of
chemical fertilizers with compost that's
only so what I say about the emissions
from the compose application so we have
estimated that the compost will cause
emissions but they will also add carbon
into the soil and in the organic farming
systems the accumulation of carbon will
be six times higher than the emissions
caused because of the composing so they
we don't need to worry about that is
about the same case in the conventional
one the next one please
next please
okay as I said before they have our
forces systems where there are banana
crops and trees useful also for the bees
they produce honey so it's important and
there are the trees covering the the the
coffee plants and district agencies - in
a capture rate for co2 assist sets in
conventional
2.33 3233 and organic a little bit lower
because they have more trees in the
conventional ones so this important to
bear in mind because of the next slide
please
next
yeah so one of the importance of this
project is that because of the coffee
rust especially the conventional farmers
are tempted to switch from the bars that
they already have to more resistant
varieties to the coffee Li rust and the
problem is that these darts approach
with this the car these this plants
needs more light so they will cut the
trees they're already there and this
coffee the quality of this coffee is not
that good and the pro means that these
organization Prada coke is well
positioned in the market because of the
quality of the coffee so they will lose
market and they won't get the fur trade
price they already have that complete so
this is what we expect to happen with
the project it's another representation
we already have measured the baseline we
have already measured what is the
increase in carbon sequestration because
the shift from conventional systems
including organic farming but by
implementing a compulsion facility we
would spec this carbon right
sequestration two-spirit to be boosts
and then this is what would be the
additionality of the project that would
be offered in the market and the carbon
markets next one please so again the
composting facility will go to the
coffee plantations we expect this to
increased yields and to increase also
carbon in soil and we get further carbo
prayers that will be used for paying
back the investment in the composting
facility next one please
sir
so their benefits sorry are a you
increase the yields to have a better
control of the diseases especially the
coffee Li rust and there's something we
already have found that by using organic
fertilizer to improving the nutrition of
the plant we better we get better a
taste way better a higher qualification
of the other of the coffee if they have
a better taste so they can claim for a
higher price and we have seen also we
have measured for example from reduction
from 20 to 5 percent reductions in the
the defective coffee beings so this is
very important for the in terms of the
yield and the quantities they can sell
into the quality markets next one please
so we expect from this product to
increase the income from having higher
yields to improve the quality of the
coffee to reduce the losses because of
the coffee beans and of course because
reducing also the losses due to the
diseases I'd report the likelihoods and
we belong we believe that a stronger
former organizations is a key key issue
in order to promote the creation of
farming and no farming jobs in in the in
the communities to demand services and
to promote then a more dynamic economy
they're in their own landscapes
so thanks for your attention
and I hope your questions later Thank
You Francisco
[Applause]
yeah now I want to introduce you to
revert to googas revert to a gaseous
member of the board of f1 but it is also
a research researcher in the university
la melena here improve the Vertigo
flourishes when Finella presentation for
for no it won't be easy
good morning in contrar Oh
I will report about a household survey
that we conducted a few months ago in
the Peruvian Andes and we try to
understand the relationship between
Agricola G livelihoods and food security
this was part of a project project
funded by Canadian development agencies
in which we had collaboration with
Peruvian and Canadian organizations and
our main partner in the field with the
National Association of ecological
farmers when we speak of ecological
farmers in the context of this report we
don't mean third party certified farmers
but non certified organic farmers and
they are involved in other types of
guarantee systems for organic farming
like participatory guarantee systems the
fact is that in spite of the very strong
economic growth of the last two decades
in Peru the situation in the Peruvian
Andes remains more or less similar and
the differences between urban and rural
population remains more or less the same
this is a map the official Peruvian map
of the vulnerability to food insecurity
and as you can see the red color are the
districts with a highest vulnerability
to put insecurity it follows almost
exactly the Andean Highlands to the east
you have the Amazon to the west you have
the coast where almost 70% of our
population leads so in spite of this
economic growth and all the public
discourse about the importance of
traditional cultures in ditional people
and biodiversity the fact is that when
it comes to poverty and food insecurity
particularly in the high Andes the
situation is more or less the same so we
I cannot read I'm sorry I have to turn
around what we wanted was to
characterize small landholders according
to their Agricole article practices to
analyze the relationship between rural
livelihoods with emphasis on natural
financial physical human and social
capital and Agricole ajikko practices
and to explain food security as an
effect of Agricola chico practices and
selected indicators of
livelihoods so we developed the research
first of all trying to understand the
context in terms of social demographics
environmental profile and Agricola
Jeckle production we under try to
understand and through a household
survey we made several questions about
natural physical financial and human and
social capital and in the end we try to
analyze it the effects on food security
we divided the population in two main
groups agro ecological farmers were at
least 70% of the farms were under
Agricole ajikko practice they had not
used chemical inputs for the last three
years and they were implemented at least
one of the following one practice in
each of the following category using
organic manures soil and water
conservation crop diversification and
ecological pest control on the other
hand the conventional farmers were
living in the same communities as a
research group of the Agricola Jeckle
group with similar characteristics have
not been exposed to the Agricola local
perspective or does not know or they did
not know about them and implemented
conventional practices at least one of
the following using chemical fertilizers
chemical insecticide fungicide or plant
growth hormones so we I'm sorry this is
this is the size of the sample that we
implemented we worked in three regions
the northern Andes cajamarca the central
Andes Juanico and the southern part of
the end is cusco and the total number of
farmers were 221 Agricola Tico 230
conventional with a total sample 451
households this is the first time that
this type of comparison is done in Peru
and what we wanted to gather of course
concrete facts about the effect of the
agro-ecological implementation besides
the ideological discourse and this is
the type of farmers we got information
from they could have been like in the
left
it's very small tomato grower in the
northern Andes then they a woman growing
vegetables for the local markets in
Cusco under plastic tunnels or very
traditional farmers growing native
potatoes above 4,000 meters sea level
what all of them have in common is that
they practice Agricola G and they belong
to the National Association of
ecological farmers or were linked to
such organizations the results were very
different and when it comes to the
social demographic graphic profile we
found statistical differences for
example by the in the educational level
achieved by the mother and in general
there was a high statistical significant
differences and the Agri collage achill
households tended to speak more Spanish
than the conventional farmers this has
something to do of course with their
access to the formal educational systems
which is basically all done in Spanish
when it comes to the farming system
profile 99 almost a hundred percent of
the agricultural households could
distinguish an agro-ecological practice
with only one third in the conventional
almost 80 percent of the conventional
households did not have any external
support compared to only 54 percent in
the Agricola chico households the agora
collage achill households used more
external labour
16:1 compared to 40 percent and they
were also highly more interested in
growing new crops and diversifying their
production the sources of seats was
statistically significant with
significant differences
produced by themselves or exchanged with
other farmers with comparison to the
conventional which were more reliant on
the modern market when it comes to the
Agricola Chico practices the use of
organic manure soil and water
conservation and crop diversification we
asked what was the situation five years
ago and what was the situation today as
you can see the Agricola
you call farmers five years ago 80%
implemented these Agricole ajikko
practices and five years later this
climbed up to almost 100 percent while
in the conventional group it changed
from 40 to from 50 to 57 in five years
so not a large increase over there when
it comes sorry when it comes to the soil
and water management practices five
years ago in the Agricola yoga group
there was an increase from 75 to 99
percent in five years while in the
conventional group it remained more or
less the same with regards to the
cropping diversification systems in the
Agricola Jekyll group the increase was
similar from 82 to almost 100 while in
the conventional group it moved from
fifty to sixty seven when we
characterized natural capital they were
very interesting differences there
the conventional group with significant
differences expressed that their their
soils were exhausted and also in 40% of
the cases that the erosion has increased
the Agricola Jekyll households practiced
pressurized irrigation systems three
times more than the conventional they
have planted trees you see 85 percent
versus 65 percent in the conventional
and they consider that water to be
contaminant free seventy five versus
sixty percent when it comes to financial
capitals the Agricola chico had a clear
stronger connection with markets and to
credit sources so they usually were
selling their products in the local
farmers market municipal markets while
in the conventional there were other
types of market connections and which is
very importantly in these years in Peru
the percentage of families participating
in government social programs was higher
in the Agra collage achill group as
compared to the conventional and there
were also significant differences in
access to
when it comes to physical capital there
were significant differences sorry one
minute okay I will run a little there
were not many important differences when
it comes to physical capital when it
comes to the perception of family income
you can see in the top the
agroecological showed responded that
their income has barely improved or has
improved substantially well the
conventional mentioned that their income
remained the same with regards to social
capital that were of course the normal
differences basically because most of
the agro-ecological farmers belong to
farmers association and when required to
answer why they belong to this
organization 66 percent mentioned to
access new markets when we decided with
the start of the growing season when
food reserves have already been finished
and there were some difference there
between Agricole ajikko and conventional
so our preliminary conclusions are that
we had a solid sampling allowing the
detection of differences between
Agricola jekyll and conventional however
this is the first study of its kind a
Greek illogical household showed a
better performance in the five
dimensions of food security there are
normally four dimensions of post
security but we have really found that
institutions should be added at one of
us one of the dimensions with regards to
natural and social capital there were
clear differences not so much with human
and physical women had a higher
participation and and this is relevant
for what we are discussing today that
very often Agri collage achill
households tend to be located in similar
similar micro watersheds and are
organized increasing the relevance of
key indicators related to climate change
where they performed better there are
many other conclusions that we are
deriving right now but one very
important is in general the
institutional context in which these
households operate is weak or very weak
and there is a really strong need for
stronger government presence of good
quality thank you
Thank You Loretta we have one to two
minutes to clarification questions if
there's some in the audience
No okay well thank you hurry Francisco
and Roberto yeah you have one could you
please come in front
[Music]
Commerce Ernestina capacity
muchas gracias rosemary a Gallaudet
sentry Zayas me pregunta es para el
representante de voz en lo relaciones o
a los Beauty historias Beto a la
posibilidad para poder reciclar la
materia organic la pregunta que tengo es
el proyecto crew stairs implement ro la
dimension Elvin looming ec2 Vieira
inversiones public Assisi converter own
en polticas para para ellos 'es Paseos
porque en nuestro Pais tenemos la gran
limitation de como este diamond Aviles
say Misiones con el tema de las horas y
lo recede Oso ledo's entonces esto como
posibilidad para poder mesophyll carlo
okay so our current system is or current
programs are with the small holders in
rural areas so they bio cash registers
they are based on using the menu from
the cows the cow dung mainly or
sometimes the pigs
it perfectly you can mix it with other
inputs organic waste but in general we
do not recommend it because then there's
a risk that people don't know how how
which are the materials that could be
damaging the process and yeah so the the
the program is just based on the the cow
dung the pig dung and human extra for
the first phase now so in future when
people are more accustomed to to the
system we might change that but and of
course here in in in for the waste
management it's also in also in urban
areas very beneficial but we focus for
the moment on the on the who
Arius and I think the Russian another
part in your question but I don't
remember I want to hold your questions
because we want to move to the panel and
I want to introduce the panel and then
we can interact within the panel no I
said at the beginning that we will
divide this session into you we already
have seen three excellent cases in
Africa Kenya and Indonesia presented by
Harry also Nicaragua presented by
Francisco and presented by Roberto and
and now we want to also welcome to the
floor Peter bomb in about a his director
of business development and not used of
the gold standard Foundation Christian
Danika his director of land using carbon
of South Pole say he owes alanya he is a
special advisor of global issues as in
un CCD Richie hue his regional director
of Asia for the Environmental Defense
Fund and well I didn't introduce myself
I can follow so this a problem officer
of ethos also for the regional for the
region of the Andes so this panel we
want to make it as interactive as
possible and we want to start with
innovation I will shut the first
question and then we can continue from
from that point and maybe Harry you can
explain you have already explained the
scale but could you or someone in in the
table can set something about what is
innovative of these approaches and and
then we come to your question oh so yeah
well one thing is innovative nation the
in the scale yeah so it's really
such biocare systems already have
existed for a long time but the programs
they bring in a market-based approach
where the people get access so we work
on the demand side we work with the with
the MFIs
and also the supply side with the local
Commission's that construct us and yeah
that's that's a system so it's and it's
the scale well I don't know if that was
part of the kind of the of the the
question but we are in Indonesia we have
now thirteen thousand households with
biogas digesters and you can hear that
twelve thousand okay do you have a
question okay yeah could you
yeah maybe you can repeat the question
because it is to the expert from Peru
I'm Charlotte from National Council for
sustainable development India we have
exhibition upstairs my question is to
the expert from Peru that analysis which
were showed about agro-ecological
practices whether it is pure organic
farming or it is organic farming or
organic manure mixed with chemical
fertilizer because we have found in our
experience ok we have found in our
experience with large number of farmers
small farmers if you directly take up
only organic farming it's not viable
because if it is not based on soil
health analysis right so if you just put
organic and soil health analysis
requires different nutrients then your
farming is not viable so I just want to
find out from the expert from Peru
what was their situation and if I can
add something maybe you can address a
little bit of what innovative approaches
you have you have seen in in the
experience in in Peru we made a clear
sampling and the difference was food
from the beginning the agro ecological
group about 250 farmers were using were
implementing different Agricole ajikko
practices and have not used any chemical
input for the last three years on the
other hand the conventional farmers were
practicing agriculture in a similar
agro-ecosystem but we're using at least
one chemical inputs and a results show
and the practice shows in Peru that
there is a very high viability for
ecological farmers in certain conditions
this is specifically related to the high
Andes and what is innovated about this
approach I think the
strongest innovation whoo empowering
what I reported was the close
interaction between farmers organization
sometimes powerful farmers organizations
and development agencies made many times
local NGOs or other groups even groups
of restaurants teaming together to buy
produce from them so I would say the
most relevant innovation in this context
belongs to social capital
thanks you Roberta and did this bring me
to the next question to Francisco what
is the role of other players you present
a case on coffee what is the role of
private sector in in that you listen
yeah actually one of the approaches we
are pursuing is to convince Roasters
buyers of coffee for them to understand
what is the program behind low
productivity and higher risk for climate
change of these coffee farmers so we
believe they can play a great role by
contributing in these investments
initial investments for scaling up these
kind of alternatives for the farmers to
increase yields and to become more
better adapted to the climate change to
manage better their the diseases and to
also we also pursue the investments goes
to diversification of the system so they
can not only depend on coffee so they
can also get income from other sources
so I believe these players need these
increasing in yield they need the
farmers to be in the field producing
because it's their own business they
need to continue their own business so
actually it's a win-win relationship
they would expect by supporting these
kind of activities of course the
financial institutions together with the
parrot sector may join
support these initiatives and to become
more resilient to the climate change
Thanks Francisco Peter a question for
you do you see enough room for for this
type of innovation in the injurer sector
in the carbon sector ok good morning
everyone
the I think that we're talking actually
about a lot of different things here
we're talking about certification we're
talking about organic agriculture
practices we're talking about carbon
markets what Francisco presented is
actually a case how you can increase the
production of farming systems and also
find solutions to fight things like
coffee rust one of the say proxies that
it gets out of there is the mitigation
potential that is related to it which is
I would say great news that that that
that you can combine these things there
might be other situations where the
mitigation potential is not so large but
where you still can achieve this
increase meant in production with with
adapting new practices so better
composting or increasing increasing your
soil fertility I was just getting a
figure that in 2013
24 billion tons of soil has been lost
again and a lot of these initiatives
actually look at how can we recover
these soils and make them more
productive again if carbon markets can
help with that I think that is that's
great we need any kind of finance that
helps with that whether this violence
will maybe rather come to low-carbon
supply change that is actually a concept
in which I believe more where we see we
will see a lot of movement as the coffee
roasters and the coffee supply chains
himself have an interest it's still
being in business in 10 or 20 years from
now so you see in these sectors and
ever-increasing willingness to invest in
supply chains and increase the
production sustainably at source when it
when it really comes to the carbon
component I think there should be some
concern
expressed as well the negotiations
during the week and also next week and
next year in Paris are making our making
process I think there's a lot of new
thinking going on and a more
decentralization of contributions but
also the question is going to be who's
going to pay for all these actions that
we want to see on the ground and we're
always talking about leveraging private
capital but in fact there's not too much
private capital in the rooms here and
not in the negotiation rooms either so
these are examples where it can actually
work and where I think the certification
for example also leads to other side
effects than just these effects but I do
have a concern more about about the
financing part of say the overall green
transition but we will definitely talk
about it more in and I definitely think
that finds requires innovative mechanism
on incentives
maybe Ricci you can it gives us a little
bit of background about market
innovations that you have seen in the
field that can bring this to scale for
instance ICT can you all hear me oh
great
so my name's Richie Ahuja with the
Environmental Defense Fund and terrific
presentations from Harry Francisco and
Roberto and we are doing something
similar on the ground in India and so
I'm going to draw up on that well of
experience as well where we're working
with about 70 80 thousand households for
biogas units about 100,000 households
for cook stoves and 2030 thousand
farmers it is a landscape approach and
I'm I'm loving the fact that everybody
here is talking about landscape
approaches and one thing I would caution
on is sort of on the finance pieces that
don't do this for the carbon finance
what you do this for is because it makes
economic sense for the farmer so it has
to start from that place and if it so
happens that in the process because
we're doing all the things right you're
going to get some benefits which are
carbon benefits it is then up to
the aggregator or the government in play
or whoever to figure out if you want to
monetize that asset and if you see value
in monetizing that asset to drive or
catalyze more transformation on the
ground so the jury is still out but it
is certainly I'm glad that more and more
people are exploring this Avenue it's
not a done deal yet there's also some
issues around permanence so we need to
think through on that as well but I
think the rigor that needs to be done
there's nothing we need more and more
rigor more and more data points to show
that what's being done is real that the
development effects are really what we
say they are that transaction costs are
manageable on finance there's various
sources of finance we have leveraged
some monies from you know this Oda and
philanthropic funds to build
institutional capacity to test things
out but there's huge amounts of money
that governments like my government in
India for example spends on development
that's their business they spend on
agriculture so there's budgetary line
items we should think about how they can
be leveraged and used better and made
more efficient there's money from credit
agencies where a lot of the small
farmers on our credit so can we figure
out ways to get debt to them which is
low-cost debt there's social impact
investments and then there's also the
whole carbon deal so the idea is to
figure out ways to blend all this
together and come up with a solution
that works for that particular place and
context coffee farmers cent or into cash
crops so they may perhaps have more
availability in terms of credit
creditworthiness and if they have tenure
on the line etcetera hours you've
talking about a small-scale farmer in
upland or dryland agriculture in central
India then your issues are they're a
little bit there's issues around credit
worthiness and availability of banking
etc but all this is changing so there's
places you've talked about ICT you know
phone banking is coming into play in
Africa phone banking is happening in
India now just right off the phone phone
systems credit is being made more
available to the farmers GIS systems are
being brought in to apply to ensure that
farm ownership is clearly defined and
all this is very very exciting because
it's going to open up the space for the
farmer to again access the funds that
the farmer needs to optimize
land use and also all this information
system is going to be very valuable for
the farmer in the end also to take the
right decisions in the end where I come
from on all this is that the farmer is
really the best optimizer of resources
on the ground they're not in the
business of wasting resources but what
they do best is you know if they have
the right amount of information they'll
take the debt right decisions the
challenge is getting them the
information thank you and moving from
innovation to livelihood so resilient
naively hood's Christian maybe you can
explain us how these approaches from the
landscape perspective builds on
resilient livelihoods
I'll project there you go thank you
thanks for the question and actually we
did start a while ago what which he said
you shouldn't do which is looking a lot
at carbon finance and we collected some
experience on that in a in a organic
farm in a organic farming focused
project and we draw some lessons from
that basically the project was not only
organic farming itself but it was an
intervention to save forests it's a LED
intervention in the end so what was done
is basically the upscaling of
conservation and organic farming in
Mason millet production through
activities such as compositing precision
planting and erosion harassing and so on
but we framed that also with additional
activities fairly soon which were around
enabling conditions to allow that had to
happen for example fire management there
was a lot of wildfires that spread from
other farms or from poaching activities
into the fields which and then burnt the
biomass that you needed for the organic
farming and we also needed to diversify
the workload over the year so we looked
at honey production and we looked at and
nutrition gardens next to the villages
so that created more work when there was
no other work to do and we looked also
into fertilizer producing trees such as
tighter BIA and additional food crops
such as Moringa and finally we framed
that as I said with a common methodology
using the VCS and the CCPs and so what
we found is that actually the carbon
finance in the end was only you needed
to kick-start activities at the start
and then the project is sort of rolling
out itself by itself now of course it's
being you know supported ongoing with
carbon but the the project managed to to
raise 30 percent productivity of a glove
staples outputted managed to generate
$400 aprox of income per honey farmer
per year which is about replicating the
income they had before so we saw that
carbon
was an excellent Kickstarter and if
there would be a better carbon price we
could do a lot more because the project
is at 800,000 hectares with several
hundred thousand people so it could be
rolled out and I hope that in the
negotiations that you know the enabling
conditions will be set for that so maybe
some lessons there one was that the it
was key to maintain the to avoid leakage
and maintain that conditionality that we
know we do this for a purpose and which
also includes mitigation as honestly for
the local population as the second most
important priority but the other finance
providers most important one and
therefore it was key to make sure that
there was a land use planning set for
example there were bore holes that were
dried up since decades partially and
before rehabilitating those since
starting organic farming that we looked
at is that in a biodiversity cornea or
or not and then we focused on those that
community said and we looked after that
are not in the middle of an area that is
sensitive our second point is that work
generation was key you don't want to
generate more outcome with less work
because then people spend that time
opening new areas and it fasoli this was
also little facilitated because it's
really a non market environment there's
almost no one going to the markets at
selling excess crops so as long as they
have this production they need and a
little excess for paying school fees for
kids there's not a lot of expansion
going on and with regards to that
negotiations I mean it would be nice if
the technologies that have been
presented here and then are being used
at the landscape approach could receive
the adequate support by either
market-based mechanisms or by the Green
Climate Fund or other discussions that
are ongoing it's going slow so meanwhile
what the positive messages all these
projectors have been mentioned here are
probably the most sexiest one that you
have on the voluntary car market it's
hard it's not a big market but meanwhile
those are those projects that probably
fetch the best prices things
thank you I tend to talk too much and so
if you please have questions just raise
your hands meanwhile I have one for the
case holders Harry Francisco Berto
basically your cases were talking about
mitigation and how you can reduce the
amount of carbon output what about
adaptation and food security
well actually the use of the bio slurry
also has great benefits for the food
security and the adaptation first of all
the food security now because it's yet
used the bio salary is often used for
growing new crops nearby in the house so
this new particle vegetables and food
crops coming into the home system yeah
and then next to that the get fertile as
I mentioned it's a good fertilizer and
it's because it's also containing the
micronutrients it's improving the soil
condition the soil structure so that is
also making an impact on the resilience
and yeah depth against possible negative
radical impacts and climate impacts so I
think there's clearly an adaptation
benefit as well maybe you want to add
more on that
okay okay yeah from we one way of
looking at this is farmers are already
by using improve endure their their
income they would be able to buy some
other food that they already taking a
yet because of the they have a very low
income but we are also increasing or
encouraging the farmers to diversify
their production in the case of product
they also are producing honey bee and
they are getting income from there we
have seen in other cases of
diversification that farmers themselves
were able to pay the renovation of the
plant of the coffee plantations because
other sources that they are selling
recently like a small farming small
vegetable facilities are they are
selling to the market they also having
chicken eggs and some small animals and
some cows and they are diversifying in
this way they are reducing the risk and
they are getting income from other parts
so this is our contribution for the food
security in food insecurity they already
have
oh yeah
thank you very much my name's bill her
ditch from Australia
thanks for the fantastic presentations
of the case studies I just had a
question for the panel about the
application of this type of innovation
to broader scale landscapes we've talked
a little more about small holders here
but in Australia for example we've got
millions and millions of hectares of
extensive rangelands some on the edge of
deserts and we're doing some work in the
north on the application of technology
by way of better water access for large
large areas opportunities to increase
biodiversity sell grazing and reduction
of wildfire so just a general question
to the panel about the application of
organic farming or agro-ecological
farming processes to broader scale
landscapes around the world because in a
way because of the climate issues and
adaptation and mitigation will rely a
lot on big areas of land being recovered
and rehabilitated and put into better
food production
for giving me the opportunity to also
put the my hair in the soup of this this
issue and I agree with with your your
question this is how this very
innovative examples on cases that I am
very grateful to be here mean here this
morning and listening to these very
highly relevant examples at the small
scale and how large-scale operations
also can can benefit from this issue how
can this change can be driven not only
at the at the on the ground but also the
financial aspects this is a challenge
that we have in front of us and if we
include in this in this in this soup as
I said the the negotiation process of
where why we are here in in Lima today
the Climate Change Conference well let
me say first that I work in the other
convention that came out of three or one
of the three creo there were three
conventions for those of you who don't
know if you already know I'm sorry I
would have to repeat this the climate
change convention is only one of the
three real conventions that were agreed
upon in 1992 the other one is
biodiversity Convention and the
desertification convention I work in the
desertification convention from that
angle
I can say that it is a challenging to to
see the common denominator of these
presentations the soil organic carbon or
carbon content in the soil how is this
going to be adopted and embraced by the
negotiators in the in the I mean some
kilometers away from here this is not
something that we can hope and we can
wish this is something that we have to
advocate and fight for and 20 years have
passed by discussing about in the
inclusion of land and soil into the
negotiation of climate change and
nothing has happened in Kyoto in Curtin
1997 for example III at that time I had
my hair black we in Kyoto the the
Europeans they said you know we want a
cane
Kalli pure a great protocol chemically
pure means means land and forest out of
the negotiation and that was what they
got no they got the Kyoto Protocol the
way they wanted it this energy business
and now in order to include the the
issues of land and soils and water and
for a vegetation it's going to be
challenging Christiana Figueres
mentioned this month
this past Monday she wants an universal
agreement for Paris universe of the
world Universal includes this issue but
I don't know how it is going to happen
if we only well it's good that we have
this this innovative cases and that we
reflect and highlight the the issue of a
soil carbon content but we have to pass
this message in events like this and
individually to those negotiators there
are other issues on not only on
mitigation mitigation is great and good
as well the issues about adaptation and
food security what happened to other
indicators that are out there like for
example the land productivity dynamics
net primary product how can we use that
Indyk in the within the framework of
this convention or the trends in land
cover these are a lot the indicators for
the resilience of the of the land so
there are options that we out there many
research is has been done that it can be
used and this is one side the other side
is a financial issue it's true that that
there are many resources out there that
the national level in other investing
and private investments but how to
jumpstart how to drive this change how
the Green Climate Fund or the Jeff or
the CDM or all these other financial
mechanisms that they discussed here for
years and years in the convention how
can this be the seed to create this
change and I don't see the eligibility
of
projects that have this this soul
component or land component be included
Richard Wright the the gentleman from
you mentioned sorry you mentioned about
the methodology not being agreed by the
CDM so you have to work on this
methodology to include the soil carbon
content but this is not the only case
how we can do this to actually make this
project eligible for for this carbon
financing and adaptation finance this is
the challenge we have in terms of
metrics also sure I'll just take one
minute it's a very good question on
scale love it
one I think want to bring up the issue
of adaptation mitigation I think it's
not a question of either/or we live on a
spectrum so no matter what you do on
mitigation off and you get adaptation
benefits or a few packages inhabited
updation you get mitigation benefits
what's important I think is for us to
know where we are and what those
elements are the components how much and
in terms of scale we are having these
negotiations and and it's great and I
think they can add value in terms of
trying to drive scale but really scale
happens at home it happens is driven by
local interests which has in the
individual farmer and by national
interest we need to serve those and to
do that we need to basically these
examples are great and we need more and
more of these examples that are very
much data driven with strong metrics
that really make the economic case you
know governments typically look at money
going into this sector as a cost and we
need to start looking at that as an
investment and the moment we can show
very categorically that here are the
returns on that investment then you can
really start getting some scales so the
more number of projects you had the good
more data you have you get build
confidence so that's kind of the stuff
that we are beginning to see with some
of our work we're moving from
project-based approaches now to try and
drive change across a whole district but
small holder farmers in Vietnam the work
we were doing in the Delta a turn are
now replicated and have the government
suddenly woken up and they
asking some good questions and I think
in the end the government is the big
driver of scale when it comes to
investments in this sector as well
including you know you need the private
sector you need other financing but in
the developing countries often the
government plays a pretty decent role
especially on interest structure etc so
to your question in the organic movement
we don't pretend to have answers for yet
for every farming system every country
in the world but there are already about
70 million hectares certified organic
worldwide and Australia is one of the
top five countries in terms of acreage
in organic land so and this only is when
we count third parties certified in
Africa Asia in Latin America there is
much more there is not yet certified but
the principles are applied on farm so we
hope to have this increased but
certainly we need to do much more
research and outreach let's move to
Finance and beta do you see what do you
see the role where do you see the role
of private investors private capital in
to to reach this scale that we are
talking about
it's a very important role if
sustainability was the business-as-usual
we wouldn't be sitting here
so the the conventions and all the
efforts at the the case studies they all
show how it can be done or they want to
kind of break through the existing
systems and come up with some new
solutions so we make things like the
Green Climate Fund and we do case
studies and we do development aid but if
we compare those sums with the finance
that is yearly going to conventional
agriculture if you know if we would ask
something for Mars to look at how we do
things here you would be saying what
what what are you doing it this doesn't
make any sense the only way in which we
can make this transition is by changing
the behavior of private capital that's
I'm totally convinced of that and it
seems so obvious to me as well
fortunately we're seeing that so there
is more and more corporates like
Unilever that are making commitments and
also putting you know they walk the talk
they make they work towards more
sustainable practices and there's many
others do that as well
there's movements in Europe in the u.s.
of people that start to appreciate again
more say also intrinsic values of of
food and and regionality and and things
like that so I think there's hope but
there's a lot that needs to be done yet
and true certification we we are partly
doing that there is examples also of
Germany where a city actually paid for
organic certification of farmers that
surround the city they said we pay for
the certification because they knew if
farmers would be organically certified
in the surroundings it will improve the
quality of the drinking water in the
city because they're not allowed to use
pesticides and chemical fertilizers
anymore
there's a lot of good examples out there
already but for real change the behavior
of this big lump of investments that is
really going into agriculture that has
to change and this is I think what we're
all trying true institutions through to
laws and regulations through
certification
and Christian so do you see a role of
the payment for ecosystem services
schemes to increase the to reduce the
impact on forest degradation then yes
this time it works I do thank you I
think it was one of the two big
frameworks that everyone is waiting for
to be set and that everyone is working
on to be said one is payment for
ecosystem services at a global scale
driven by a large-scale mechanism where
the rules are set and the reward is
clear and then the private sector could
deliver very significantly on that and
so therefore the investment to get that
done should be from the public sector
should be in setting those rules you
know and on the other hand setting the
reward in the end but not crowding out
the implementation which often can be
done by private players or together with
the public place and the other one the
other big framework is the deforestation
free supply chains and clean supply
chains that we are looking at if that
compromise that has been done this and
last year is really delivered on by lots
of large companies and we had decided
when incop some days ago people are
moving and companies are moving but
they're not really clear yet how they
will do it to get to this very shorthand
call to 2020 if that is getting traction
then you know all these technologies
here and all these initiatives that sit
on this desk will you know will get a
big boost and can probably partially
even forget about the ecosystem service
payments because there's enough Drive
without them thank you
the reality is that the carbon official
car markets are collapsed so where are
you going to sell these carbon credits
yeah well many things have been
mentioned by other panelists that I
would like to reinforce and that is for
example also that yeah don't do this for
carbon finance know it the objective is
the economic benefit of the farmer still
for the carbon finance can help to take
her to kick-start changes no and another
aspect that has not been mentioned is
that the strong monitoring impact now so
interestingly is that for carbon credits
you will need to monitor so that also
helps to to focus and to improve your
interventions because you have you have
to really to follow up on what you are
doing now so additionally also in the
biogas that were there were bad systems
better models which were distributed and
the people just count how many models
digesters have been distributed now and
with the water we know now well it's in
all the sectors it's the same so the
carbon finances that effect of good
monitoring and seeing what works about
nothing does not work but yeah clearly
so where we sell the carbon credits in
the voluntary carbon market and biogas
carbon credits are trait and relatively
good price but of course it's far from
sufficient what is needed to make a real
transition and a real impact now somehow
also Peter mentioned we need to change
behaviour of private capital maybe yeah
there's also still so much lacking but
in the two cases we have
small steps because in the Indonesia
biogas program and bio slurry does a
real contribution from Nestle know and
that was so the program is in nine
provinces at the and it performs best
where Nestle is involved now they
support the farmers and would produce
their milk and in Kenya we also after
the cooperation with EECOM trading which
is a large coffee company and it's also
investing in improving the agricultural
practices and also the base salary is a
day they submit and they are supporting
with the private capital as well
no but it's far far from what is really
needed and I would say also that
yeah carbon markets in the project-based
approach which just is the small start
to watch really promoting low-carbon
growth well I know that there are a lot
of questions but we ran out of time so I
have one last question - sir here - and
this this session so here was what
lesson lessons can we take for the
current coming sustainable development
calls discussions
hello yes with the with the topic at the
this session the how is it that the in
the sustainable development goals that
are being negotiated in New York from
December this December to to the next
August or September next year there are
17 goals and out of the 17 14 make a
reference to learn so water and
vegetation 14 out of the 17 so how is
this global Universal negotiation in New
York is going to be reflected as well in
the negotiations of this this this
convention on climate change because
what we have seen here today this
morning I mean these three very we
benefit from this innovative cases in
which organic agriculture has has a role
to play and the approaches to climate
change are really evident there but how
is this going to be reflected in the
practical approaches to the
implementation of the SDGs
it depends on the on the national and
regional structures and negotiations
that are going to run dynamic situations
that the different countries and regions
have how they will see and face these
sustainable development goals the
sustainable development goals at the
same time they will have targets so what
it could be good approach is to have
make sure that some of the targets that
this sustainable development costs have
contain the issues of land and so for
example I know that target 15.3 is the
the achievement of land degradation
neutrality which is like my integrity
and prevention and the same with in food
security the financial structures of
that that accompany the assurance of a
secure world with the regarding food and
and feed so this this issue of political
negotiation financial aspects also
include what the presenters mentioned
the how to increase social capital how
to increase livelihoods how to increase
governance at the local level how to
interact between the the small-scale
farming and the large-scale operations
in within the same a corridor within the
same country these are the issues that
perhaps we should bring to the table and
at the core of the negotiations not only
of this convention and climate change
but also the convention of the
certification and the convention
biodiversity as well as to highlighted
in the net in the in New York how we can
do this we can as I said provide the
message like demands like this but also
talk individually to the negotiators and
highlight this is important and this is
a priority for the majority of the
countries even even Germany even
Australia even India these all these
countries are based have a substantive
based on on agricultural production and
how is it that we can tap and harness
that that issue so this is what I take
home with from this event but thank you
for asking
thank you sir Hugh thank you all the
panelists and thank you all the audience
for for being here I know that we have
to close the session the lunch is
waiting for us
there are still a lot of questions I see
a lot of hands arising so but you
already know his faces you can approach
them to the breaks or to lunch or do the
coffee's and ask the questions more
specificity thank you all I think we
deserve an applause
[Applause]
you